[Música]
sou síria por nascimento designer por
opção e refugiada por obrigação até 2011
eu tinha uma vida igual à sua cheia de
planos sonhos é o mais importante
eu me sentia em casa
eu tinha uma paixão de tirar fotos de
horizontes e esse tirei da minha sacada
foi a última antes de começar a guerra
e essa é uma foto da mesma sacada de
antes só que alguns meses depois
aí eu precisei esquecer dos meus sonhos
planos e apenas sobreviver
se sobreviver antes eu ficava na varanda
tirando fotos do pôr do sol de alepo
minha cidade
depois eu ficava no quarto escondida no
quarto mais fundo de casa escutando
ouvindo as bombas caindo e agradecendo
porque cada bomba que aí conseguia ouvir
era porque não tinha morrido não daquela
vez
sobrevivendo neste ambiente de guerra
por algum tempo
você esquece como era ter sentimentos
bons você começa a sobreviver somente
sobreviver
vocês lembram quando o brasil ficou uma
semana sem gasolina
no ano passado o país simplesmente parou
bom em aleppo
nós ficamos sem luz sem água sem
gasolina e sem todo o resto das
necessidades básicas
só que durante anos as bombas caíam cada
minuto durante dois anos
aí eu precisei precisei fugir precisei
achar outra maneira para salvar minha
vida
desculpa que está pesada
[Aplausos]
neste ambiente de guerra
você vê que não tem nada mais para fazer
não tem mais futuro e comece a procurar
que se eu vou morrer de qualquer forma
então por que não viver o que me resta
então eu decidi seguir em frente
comecei a desenhar fazer trabalhos
manuais como crochê com minha avó
comecei a dar aulas de queria de de
crochê dar aulas de pintura e dança para
grupos de crianças que porque era o
único refúgio delas na guerra saudade
das minhas crianças
alguns meses depois quando alguém estava
mais tensa ainda eu precisava esquecer
do meu passado e eu recebi a notícia que
o brasil tinha aceitado meu visto
naquele momento de felicidade e tristeza
eu sabia que era hora de deixar tudo
para trás
uma semana depois eu fugi com meus pais
de aleppo no escuro em um avião de
guerra de carga bem antigo
achando que tudo estava resolvido mas aí
quando começamos a decolagem começaram
os rebeldes atiram no nosso avião e até
hoje eu não consigo esquecer o barulho
das bombas passando perto de nós e as
bolas passando perto de nós
aí eu pensei que a gente vai morrer de
verdade desta vez finalmente cheguei ao
brasil era o final de 2013
com isso surgiram grandes desafios como
aprender um novo idioma entender uma
nova cultura e além disso o mais difícil
de tudo isso era entrar no mercado de
trabalho
mas nada disso
nada disso me impediu de seguir minha
minha vida pois afinal foi por isso que
eu fugi da guerra
hoje já estabelecida com toda minha
família da síria aqui comigo no brasil
somos ainda seis pessoas só recém-casada
entrei na faculdade de design de jóias
que era uma paixão como é que começou
com aqueles crochês que eu aprendi com
minha avó na guerra e além disso tem
junto com minha família
projetos como a música culinária e
cultura que representam a síria
pois um prazer imenso poder mostrar que
podemos enriquecer ainda esta país com
nossos costumes aprendizados e
experiências
muitos aprendizados a guerra ensinou
vários clichês a não ter medo de me
jogar pro mundo
a valorizar os mínimos detalhes e a
entender que uma família unida é muito
mais forte hoje já estabelecida como era
uma vez na síria
estou cheia de sonhos planos é o mais
importante
me sinto em casa muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]